my question is so I've been uh dating my
girlfriend for about a year now and the
past few weeks she's been bringing up
moving in together and getting married
and stuff quite a bit and I I've been
married before I told her like yeah I
don't really see the point marriage I
don't really want to do it at least not
at this point in time uh same thing
about moving in she's got like a lot of
pets and I told her the same thing about
that like I don't really
see uh she's got a big dog she's got a
Chihuahua she's got three cats and she's
got a bunch of fish
oh my God yeah bring all that [__] in
your
house yeah and like the big dog she's
very like very attached to basically
treats him like a child throws birthday
parties for him and stuff how old are
you and how old is she I'm 27 she's 20
okay and uh like what's the plan like
what's the dating strategy for
you uh I'd like to keep things going um
I'd like to keep living in my own house
for the time being um she's a pretty
cool chick like all things considered
like she started doing my laundry doing
my dishes making my bed and all that
stuff without me even bringing it up
nice yeah it it very nice very agreeable
and a lot of the same Hobbies can pretty
much go anywhere and have fun doing
almost anything so okay good yeah she's
a good chick okay so what's the bad part
aside from all the
pets
uh I mean the pets are really the main
thing but a little hesitant about doing
all that stuff again after being married
and divorced and going through that it
wasn't a horrible Divorce by any means
but like still I look at my bank account
and imagine half of that being there and
i' get a little displeased you know did
you see the video that I did on the
entrepreneurs and cars Channel um
reasons why it's not ideal to live with
a woman that you
love uh I think I saw something in that
effect it it was stuff that you started
dealing with once you move in with a
with a girlfriend it might have been
something similar to that yeah I put it
out in the last month you should watch
the whole thing because it's because
it's comprehensive it covers it all um
look like unless you're planning on
having kids together
and I'm kind of
a I'm split on this right because some
guys would be like yeah live with her if
you want to have a family and children
or you can just provide for two two
households and have her raise the kids
in the other household okay yeah um
there's guys that do that and they do
that very successfully and it keeps them
Focus you know like on their purpose and
Mission are kids in the picture for
you uh she's interested in them someday
and so am I she's still got quite a
while before she's got to worry about
running out of eggs so yeah she's if
things keep going I'm not too worried
about that I guess what's her money
situation like her money situation yeah
uh I mean she can afford a small
apartment on her own and be just fine
like me I can live in apartment or she
live with her
parents uh she she just moved into her
own place she used to live with her mom
but yeah now now she's at her own place
yeah look I
mean the like one of the ways that you
can handle that conversation like stuff
doesn't usually get better when you move
in together right like right that's
that's a societal Norm that's like a
standard convention that a lot of people
sort of believe like hey you know you're
dating she's good you know she's taking
care of me she's making my bed and you
know cleaning up after herself and she's
generally a good girl except for the
[__] zoo that lives in her house
um but um what ends up happening when
you live together is things start to
change you're no longer romantic you're
no longer doing lovey doy stuff the
enthusiastic sex starts to slow down and
decline less often one of the arguments
that you could make is hey look you know
take a look around at people that are
married and live together and or live
together and you tell me how many of
them are still enthusiastic for one
another to this day there's a study that
I that I covered in my book and it was
the effect of uh long-term relationships
on love and the participants in the
study there was like I think it was 8.1
years or something like that uh the
amount of participants that reported
still being in love with with one
another was less than 133% the amount of
participants that reported still being
in a state of bliss for one another was
less than 2% so the probability of
things going into perpetuity well as
they are right now are going to decline
you're going to have fights oh your
[__] dog did this in the house and it
chewed up my this and it [__] over there
and you know like it's trying to sleep
in the bed does she sleep with the
pets yeah and like she's brought her
pets over here a couple of times and
like the Chihuahua like if you leave
them on supervised for like two minutes
he shits in the corner in the same spot
and you just can't get him to stop doing
it's like yeah and I told her it's like
I really don't want that dog here and
she stopped bringing him over yeah I
mean she might get to the point where
she gets rid of the pets and say okay I
got rid of the pets now Tom and that
would be a strong indication that she's
in your frame and has genuine burning
desire for you but still I mean if
you're not planning on having children
anytime soon why ruin what's
working right you know what I mean like
handle it from the perspective of this
is my space that's your space right stay
on your side I'll stay on my side you
know saying that basically but it's like
you know like you love your pets I
wouldn't ask you to get rid of your like
if you want to handle it from that they
just like I don't want you to get rid of
your pets but I don't want them in my
house so enjoy them in your house can I
ask how you how you would approach
dealing with that as it comes up uh
periodically I'm getting ringing
somewhere yeah yeah I canceled it how
would you deal with that conversation
coming up periodically like if if only
happens like a few times a year after
that's been established how would you
how would you bring it up what the
together yeah by just posing the same
question like women can't respond to
this I've I've never had a like a good
response to like okay so show me an
example of a couple out there that has
it all figured out that's living
together that's still in love and and
doing well still banging
enthusiastically like long into the
relationship they still care for one
another they don't fight show me because
I want to know what the secret sauce is
let's go and study them and then we'll
apply it to our relationship right
that's a good that's a very simple way
to sort of like this is my space that's
your space let's get together do our
[__] um a guy I once knew said um you
know and he was divorced and he said
something along the lines of I want to
be married again I want to sit down have
dinner hold her hand drink a glass of
wine sit by the
fireplace uh have enthusiastic fantastic
sex but then I also want to walk home to
my
house right I think I see what you're
saying man yeah so look look I
mean can you make it work sure it seems
like about 133% of people have figured
it out do I know anybody that I can like
rip off and duplicate that from no
there's nobody that I can study and say
okay well what's the secret sauce to
make that work plus you also have the
added problem of a zoo right like she's
got five right or six animals and fish
or what like she likes that which is
fine you know but if you're going to
have kids just get rid of the animals
like that's too much [__] and she can
put the effort her place smells like a
cat box too yeah like she wants to
nurture animal like something you know
which is fine like that's a nurturing
type of woman and
personality like save that for when it's
time for the kids let the animals you
know run their course you know they live
for five 10 years you know whatever ends
up happening happening you know sort of
thing but once they start going and if
you're seeing and plus you've only known
her for a year too right yeah I wasn't
planning on moving in this soon either
way usually
usually you want to wait a year and a
half two years to see what they're made
of because women can act for like the
first year year and a half right ex WIP
well you see what I'm saying right like
you're gonna deal with a representative
right so as soon as you say I do and she
has a key to your place and she moves in
or you know whatever that happens to
look like that's often when the
representative leaves and then you're
left with a real person and then you're
going to like she's going to [__] on you
because your Cabinetry is not organized
properly your pantry and she wants this
over here and that over there and this
over here and it's like why can't you
organize it the way that I've set it up
and all of a sudden now you're not
[__] that night right like you're
gonna have all kinds of these things pop
up if you just keep your life simple and
stay in your own quarters you can still
have a great experience with it right
and yeah you don't have any need to come
together because you're not going to
raise children so why why [__] something
up that's working yeah that's just my
take on it look other guys will say
other things they'll say rich is wrong
don't listen to that guy who hurt him
look my life's pretty good man I got a
great experience you know with my LTR we
don't live together uh I'm not saying
that I won't ever in the future it's
just this is the way that things roll
right now and it and it works out real
well and I've been doing it for a few
years I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out